DEMOCRAT.
>> Bret: INTERESTING RACE.
THE GENERAL IS A DIFFERENT
PICTURE.
THANK YOU.
EARLIER TODAY, I SPOKE WITH JOHN
COX WHO HOPES TO FIRST MAKE IT
ON THE BALLOT IN NOVEMBER AND
THEN UPSET THE FAVORED DEMOCRAT
LIEUTENANT GOVERNOR GAVIN
NEWSOM.
I BEGAN BY ASKING ABOUT THE KEY
ISSUES.
>> THERE'S TWO KEY ISSUES.
SANCTUARY STATE LAW WHICH THE
POLITICIANS IN SACRAMENTO PAST
AND THE PUBLIC IS UP IN ARMS
ABOUT BECAUSE IT PROTECTS
CRIMINAL ILLEGAL ALIENS INSTEAD
OF TRYING TO PROTECT LAW-ABIDING
CITIZENS IN THE POPULATION.
THE OTHER BIG ISSUE IS THE GAS
TAX AND THE CRUSHING TAX BURDEN
IN CALIFORNIA.
INSTEAD OF ACTUALLY DOING
SOMETHING ABOUT THE WASTE AND
CORRUPTION IN CAL TRANS, THE
POLITICIANS PASSED A HUGE NEW
GAS TAX, GASOLINE IN THE STATE
IS ALREADY OVER $4 A GALLON AND
IT'S GOING TO $5 A GALLON BY THE
END OF THE YEAR.
IT'S A REGRESSIVE TAX AND IT'S
CRUSHING WORKING PEOPLE.
>> Bret: THE TOP TWO DEMOCRATS
AND REALLY, YOU ARE FIGHTING FOR
ONE OF THE TOP TWO SPOTS, ON THE
ISSUE OF IMMIGRATION AT A DEBATE
EARLIER THIS MONTH, SAID THIS.
>> I THINK WE NEED TO
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT THE DREAMERS
DIDN'T COME HERE ON THEIR OWN.
WE'VE GOT TO SAY THAT THEY HAVE
A RIGHT TO HAVE LEGALIZED
STATUS.
>> I'M GOING TO PUSH BACK
AGAINST JOHN COX, TRAVIS ALLEN,
AND DONALD TRUMP.
THIS IS THE KIND OF RHETORIC
THAT HAS NO PLACE IN CALIFORNIA.
>> Bret: YOU CAN HEAR THE
CHEERS THEY ARE.
WHAT DO YOU SAY TO PEOPLE WHO
QUESTION WHETHER, IF YOU GET TO
ONE OF THE TOP TWO SPOTS, THAT
YOU CAN ACTUALLY PULL OFF A
REPUBLICAN WIN IN CALIFORNIA?
>> IAM A JACK KEMP REPUBLICAN.
I SERVED ON HIS PRESIDENTIAL
STEERING COMMITTEE IN 1997.
JACK ALWAYS CELEBRATED ILLEGAL
IMMIGRATION.
I THINK WHAT WE ARE TALKING
ABOUT HERE IS ILLEGAL
IMMIGRATION BUT MORE IMPORTANTLY
THE SANCTUARY STATE LAW IS ABOUT
CRIMINALS HELD BY
LAW ENFORCEMENT AND MS-13 GANG
MEMBERS FOR EXAMPLE.
AND THEY ARE BEING RELEASED INTO
THE POPULATION WITHOUT INFORMING
I.C.E.
I THINK THE PUBLIC IS OUTRAGED
ABOUT THAT.
IF SOMEBODY WHO HAS COMMITTED A
CRIME IS IN THE HANDS OF
LAW ENFORCEMENT, I WANT I.C.E.
INFORMED.
I WANT THAT PERSON DEPORTED.
THE DEMOCRATS ARE TRYING TO MAKE
THIS IS ABOUT RACISM.
THEY ARE TRYING TO MAKE IT ABOUT
IMMIGRATION IN GENERAL.
AND I WANT IMMIGRATION IN THIS
COUNTRY.
I CELEBRATE THE IDEA THAT THIS
COUNTRY IS THE BEACON OF HOPE
FOR THE WORLD.
BUT I DON'T WANT PEOPLE CUTTING
IN LINE.
I WANT PEOPLE COMING TO THIS
COUNTRY LEGALLY.
I THINK WE NEED TO STREAM LIVE
DOWN -- STREAMLINE THAT PROCESS.
WE I WANT A GROWING ECONOMY AND
YOU GET THAT WITH MORE PEOPLE
CONTRIBUTE IN.
I FAVOR WHAT THE PRESIDENT IS
TALKING ABOUT.
THE END TO CHAIN MIGRATION.
THE OPPORTUNITY OF PEOPLE WHO
CAN COME TO THE COUNTRY AND GROW
THE NATION AND MAKE IT CONTINUE
TO BE THE GREATEST COUNTRY IN
THE WORLD.
>> Bret: FOR PEOPLE AROUND THE
NATION, THE LIEUTENANT GOVERNOR
THERE, AT THE END YOU HEARD HIM
SAY I'M GOING TO FIGHT JOHN COX
AND DONALD TRUMP.
THE CHEERS.
IN REALITY, BECAUSE OF THE
POLITICS OF THIS PRIMARY, GAVIN
NEWSOM IS REALLY KIND OF
SUPPORTING YOU IN A WAY NOW,
ISN'T HE?
>> HE WOULD LIKE TO RUN AGAINST
ME.
HILLARY WANTED TO RUN AGAINST
PRESIDENT TRUMP TOO, AND WE KNOW
HOW THAT TURNED OUT.
PRESIDENT TRUMP IS A
BUSINESSMAN.
HE HAS ENDORSED ME BECAUSE I'M A
YOU KNOW, BRET, BUSINESS PEOPLE
LOOK FOR SOLUTIONS.
THAT'S WHAT THE PRESIDENT IS
DOING.
HE IS TRYING TO SOLVE THE
IMMIGRATION PROBLEM AND HE IS
DELIVERING RESULTS FOR THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE.
I INTEND AS A BUSINESSMAN TO
DELIVER RESULTS FOR THE PEOPLE
OF CALIFORNIA AND MAKE THIS
STATE AFFORDABLE, MAKE IT OPEN
FOR BUSINESS.
FIX OUR ROADS, FIX OUR SCHOOLS,
FIX OUR WATER SYSTEM.
MAKE THIS STATE AFFORDABLE AND
SUSTAINABLE AND LIVABLE FOR THE
WORKING PEOPLE IN THIS STATE.
MR. NEWSOM IS A POLITICIAN FROM
THE WORD GO.
HE IS A BAY AREA ELITIST.
HE'S GOING TO BE MORE OF THE
SAME, MORE JERRY BROWN BIG
GOVERNMENT, MORE TAXES AND A
CRUSHING AFFORDABILITY PROBLEM.
WE CAN'T CONTINUE DOWN THAT
ROAD.
WE ARE GOING TO GET A LOT OF
CHANGE IN 2018.